You know, you got… you got nice color skin.
Ernest: What color would you say that is?
My color.
♪
William: The Osage.
[TRAIN WHISTLE]
William: They have the worst land possible.
♪
William: But they outsmarted everybody.
William: The land had oil on it.
♪
William: Black gold.
Money flows freely here now.
I do love that money, sir.
[LAUGHS]
♪
William: This wealth should come to us.
Their time is over.
♪
William: It's just gonna be another tragedy.
Paul: When this money start comin’...
♪
Paul: We shoulda known it came with something else.
Paul: They’re like buzzards circling our people.
♪
We’re still warriors.
Mollie: I oughta kill these white men
Mollie: who killed my family.
♪
I need you here.
I am right here.
♪
William: You got to take
back control of your home.
♪
Tom: I was, uh…
sent down from Washington D.C.
to see about these murders.
See what about 'em?
See who’s doing it.
♪
[EXPLOSION]
[SCREAMING]
William: Expecting a miracle to make all this go away...
You know they don’t happen anymore.
♪